ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together for not only
the national champion bulldog not only
the butkus award winner for 2021 bulldog
but
in all honesty because this is the rich
eisen show and there is an eye in rich
and eisen
most importantly the final
toughest player on planet earth from
gorilla glue award winner of the year
nicolby
how are you nicolby dean i'm doing well
how is everything in your world
seriously tell me what the last few days
have been like for you it's kind of been
uh kind of been surreal you know uh
you know saying that you gonna i was
gonna come here and do something special
and actually being able to get it done
you know it's kind of been a feeling of
euphoria still still still haven't kind
of always hit me yet so um let's let's
walk through this here um starting with
your with your journey
is it true alabama offered you and you
chose georgia over alabama and you're
from mississippi ole miss as well is
that a true story yes it is true yeah i
had a offer from probably every sec
school but yeah it's definitely true
okay so what what attracted you to
georgia certainly over alabama what
happened there well you know i kind of
you know
i kind of prayed to god about it you
know i prayed like when i was trying to
when i was in the clutch time making my
decision i prayed to god about it and um
for some reason georgia just felt like
my good feeling you know it
it's funny because a little little known
fact when i came on my visit to georgia
i didn't really like
the football and stuff was great
everything from the football to the
academy was great but i didn't i didn't
really enjoy myself
so but a part of me and my a part of me
in my mind my psyche was like
well maybe you didn't enjoy yourself of
going out much um
yeah you'll be focused when you get here
so uh that's kind of how i looked at it
at first um and when i got here of
course i learned to enjoy athens and i
love athens i love
university of georgia yeah so when you
went what do you mean you didn't have a
good time there like you just there was
no uh yeah i just no scene yeah that's
what you said it was just like i didn't
see my uh at that point in high school
coming here i just didn't see myself uh
enjoying
okay going out being out or
you know so i feel like if i came here
i'd have to like uh venture out and
become more
uh become more outspoken so uh it was
kind of it was it kind of played along
with my growth and mature like maturity
level so that's another reason why i
chose here well you certainly have grown
and not just as a football player um
you are in mechanical engineering is
that your degree that you're you're
earning from georgia yes sir i am okay
why why that what what uh what attracted
you to that
uh
i always wanted i just knew i wanted to
do something like to help people but
growing up i always wanted to be a
doctor okay i wanted to be a doctor that
was kind of like my main thing but i
didn't want to go i didn't want to do it
going through like biology because i was
always
interested in science and uh math and
numbers
so
so
so i didn't want to do it during biology
so i was i'm gonna go i'm gonna do it uh
with i'm gonna do a mechanical engineer
like a pre-med track
i kind of got the chemistry and i was
like you know what
i don't like um
i don't like chemistry as much
so i kind of did a
drop the pre-med track and just focus uh
directly on uh mechanical engineering
you know i wanted to um
i got like uh ideas to want to like
build like prosthetics and stuff so
something like that okay so um and is it
true you got a 4-0 you you're you got
the 4-0 gpa nicole
well no it's not not necessarily true i
had a full
all the way through my my years of high
school and everything but now i got here
and it was hard well i got like a three
five
okay
all right i just found it funny nicolby
that you know that you you you're uh
you're you're into engineering when it
sure looks like it's like taking things
apart i'll be honest with you you know
just from where i'm sitting um where
does this motor come from
for you
nikoi i feel like it's my want to you
know it's uh how much i want i got i
want to be out there and i want to not
want to play the game and it i feel like
it is a certain way to play the game
you know um that's
just going all
no balls to the wall every time you know
and i feel like it starts in the off
season get yourself ready to be able to
play like that so
that's a big thing okay uh and uh and in
terms of your your defense um this year
when did you realize it could be as
special as it was going to be right from
jump
where where when was that nikobi it was
more so
[Music]
right like in in the offseason you know
when i first got back uh
after the season i had i had to get my
shoulder surgery so i was kind of out i
had kind of set for the spring
but um just seeing the work the guys was
putting in and the work we were all
putting in from uh from not only a
physical standpoint but from a mental
and a personable standpoint
um getting to know each other better
connection and everything it was like
yeah we can do something special and i
feel like
i i i kind of was uh putting in position
to i had to step up as far as being a
leader i always i already felt like i
was a leader but i felt like i could uh
take the next step of being a leader and
leading this team and leading the
defense
so
that was my biggest thing so
doing the off-season just seeing the way
we worked and the way the coaches were
locked in they were just as locked in as
us and seeing the team shift to a
player-led team other than like the
coaches trying to lead and coaches got
to push us and shift to a player-led
team that's when i knew this team would
be special the kobe dean toughest player
on planet earth final gorilla glue award
winner of the year right here on the
rich eisen show few more minutes left
with the national champion so let's talk
about the journey here as well
do you think you would have gone
to where you went eventually and won it
all
if you had not
lost to alabama in the sec championship
game was that a necessary part of your
journey do you think the kobe dean yeah
i mean you know the world may never know
but but they lost i say they lost the um
they lost in the sec championship kind
of woke us up you know
uh
like uh jordan davis like to say he was
smelling sauce you know it woke you up
it was like um
yeah we not invincible we uh we can't be
beat so
um i wouldn't i don't want to say it but
i kind of felt like
before that game it was kind of like
yeah we going to beat him we were so
confident that
a little bit of complacency set in we
thought that everything was going to
take care of itself and that we just
didn't have to go out and do it
so then i feel like after that loss it
was like
ain't no like we can't get complacent
like
the thing that we've been working
towards all year all off season can be
ticked can be taken from us
uh any point of time in the game so we
we after that we just looked at
everything like a one game season in to
get the job done so
just not being not becoming complacent
to continue to work you know like i like
to say hard work works
well you know i i think you know uh i i
really
just love watching you play and how fast
you fly to the football and you know you
got in the face of one of your teammates
during the national championship game
when it appeared like he was kind of
picking you off from trying to make the
your play and and his response your
teammates response was kind of like to
understand
you know where you were coming from like
you're clearly the leader in the
heartbeat right in the middle of this
defense and it's a testament to my
professionalism that i'm happy to give
you this award nicolby because i don't
know if you're aware i'm a university of
michigan wolverine fan
seems like he did not know that
and
you made my new year's eve miserable
miserable nicole
yeah i didn't know that at all
and i'll be honest i was wondering how
many number 17s do they have and then i
realized there was only one it was just
you
[Laughter]
you know is there five of them that's
what i honestly thought
so
uh
[Music]
were you like sitting there in the
meeting room leading up to the orange
ball saying we got these guys because it
sure felt like i was i was watching that
game uh
you could be honest yeah well you know
i'll be honest
i'm confident any every game so i'm
telling i'm always telling the guys that
we got this our game we gotta go out to
and perform and we kind of feel
disrespected it was uh
for some reason i don't know like um
like we i never felt like we had like
anything like
like beef with bishken so to speak but
like fans was like crazy
like they would like as soon as they
found out that we was playing them they
would view me every day under my
comments like
crazy it was just like everybody on our
team
it was crazy but we we were kind of we
we were mad because um
like
everybody wasn't you know
kind of people were saying that we was
uh we was undeserving of uh
of like the spot we had because we
because the way we lost in alabama we
was uh overrated and everything like
that so we came out we we did play a
little uh pissed off and and they
tipping our shoulder on it only got
bigger
yeah i i don't know who was dming you uh
to say that that we had you uh
no that was you
that would be the time to apologize
yes go ahead and apologize in the cocoa
nicolby can look and you can look in
your dms you know that wasn't me i would
never do something like that burner
account no you your fans hadn't won in
40 years and you saw the outpouring of
love like this was huge for us we beat
ohio state and all that business and
so
yeah understand that i can't i'm not i'm
not following the fans at all okay very
good so uh who who is the last couple
for you nicole dean do you know who's
the one who handed you the alabama
championship hat after the game
no
i didn't i do not know actually so um
i would they they found the video on my
reaction and everything that's great
the person giving me the hat
your reaction when you saw the hat was
just like you know what is this about
like you saw that yeah and i was
thinking to myself i just did a whole
interview
with the alabama hat own
logo towards the camera it was like what
like
but you know i kind of i ran with it
though i kept like i didn't care i just
wanted a hat
uh no matter what i mean of course i
wanted to say georgia on it but of
course you need the g
okay uh and then stetson bennett the
fourth what what what did it mean for
you to see him play like that you know
he was crying you know his story you had
a front row seat for the whole thing so
uh you know it meant a lot it means a
lot just being able to play with him and
uh calling him my brother you know just
seeing the way he worked he inspired uh
i know he inspired me
to keep going no matter what
the adversity is so how did he inspire
you what do you mean
he's just his this is just his whole
story his whole story the way he worked
the way he he don't complain he just
comes in and works and uh handling his
business and uh do his job so
just seeing somebody like that you know
leading by example you know um you know
inspires me no matter where i go no
matter how hard it gets just continue to
work continue to trust yourself and
believe in yourself and don't dodge
yourself and you know continue to work
you know it was just special being able
to see him uh prove a lot of that is
wrong
well nicoby dean you you've won a lot
you've got uh the national championship
you're part of a
historic team uh the butkus award um and
and so many accolades but now i have to
be honest with you this is the biggest
you are the toughest player on planet
earth
uh from gorilla glue from all of us here
at the rich eisen show in case you're
wondering it's a thousand dollar check
and free glue product and then of course
all of the trimmings of walking around
campus as such just ask jordan davis he
was the first one yeah i remember that
okay so
all right now you are such and uh
i will ask do you need what what needs
fixing in your world what can the glue
or the tape or the products from gorilla
glue help you with nicolby dean what do
you got anything man everything
you ask me i'm uh
it's like uh i'm going back to square
one you know it's a new uh
seize nowhere i'm gonna uh
let your body rest and rebuild so i'm
working on everything so they do need to
help me put together every single thing
okay uh am i going to and i'll just
throw this one out there
answer how you wish am i going to see
you at the uh nfl scouting combine
in a couple weeks in indianapolis
i would tell
time will tell
okay but you're focused on sundays at
some point right correct
who's your guy who do you want to come
to the nfl and emulate who do you got
uh
just be the best version myself of
course but i feel like if i can't uh if
i can work and i can be the best version
of myself you know everything uh would
turn out well
well okay i'll be honest with you i'm a
jet fan too i think you'd look
incredible in green kobe i've said this
before i'll say it again um very very
excited to see what you can do at the
next level and i hope to hear on that
subject very soon
thank you you are very very welcome
chris you want to ask a question is this
sarah tiana another georgia bulldog fan
would want to know something from the
kobe yeah she's just excited that nicoby
follows her back on twitter oh you did
are you you know that right nicoby the
comedian sarah tiana do you know every
single one that you follow on twitter i
do not know everybody
she would want me to thank you nakobi
for providing her probably the greatest
fall of her life
no problem well she's a braves fan too
i'm sure you know a lot of those georgia
bulldog fans who uh root for the atlanta
braves what are they different oh my god
i thought they were on the hat was
forever
oh my gosh
that is funny
oh man hey kobe dean congratulations on
being the toughest player on planet
earth we think you are a perfect
embodiment of what the award is all
about more than just football being that
glue guy and winning the national
championship thanks for the time all
right thank y'all you got it
on the rich eisen show